we are all broken that's how the light
gets in
we're stronger in the places that we've
been broken
no one you love is ever truly lost
[Music]
there is no friend as loyal as a book
[Music]
to hell with them
nothing hurts if you don't let it
in order to write about life first you
must live it
[Music]
all things truly wicked start from
innocence
the hard part about writing a novel is
finishing it
if two people love each other there can
be no happy end to it
you know it makes one feel rather good
deciding not to be a [ __ ]
[Music]
i didn't want to kiss you goodbye that
was the trouble i wanted to kiss you
good night and there's a lot of
difference
[Music]
it's none of their business that you
have to learn how to write let them
think you were born that way
all my life i've looked at words as
though i were seeing them for the first
time
[Music]
there is no rule on how to write
sometimes it comes easily and perfectly
sometimes it's like drilling rock and
then blasting it out with charges
the real reason for not committing
suicide is because you always know how
swell life gets again after the hell is
over
if a writer stops observing he is
finished
experience is communicated by small
details intimately observed
death is like an old [ __ ] in a bar i'll
buy her a drink but i won't go upstairs
with her
[Music]
the world is a fine place and worth
fighting for and i hate very much to
leave it
[Music]
i loved you when i saw you today and i
loved you always but i never saw you
before
why do old men wake so early is it to
have one longer day
[Music]
but life isn't hard to manage when you
have nothing to lose
there isn't always an explanation for
everything
[Music]
you know i don't love anyone but you you
shouldn't mind because someone else
loved me
[Music]
why darling i don't live at all when i'm
not with you
when you love you wish to do things for
you wish to sacrifice for
you wish to serve
i'm not unfaithful darling i've plenty
of faults but i'm very faithful you'll
be sick of me i'll be so faithful
there is nothing to writing all you do
is sit down at a typewriter and bleed
happiness in intelligent people is the
rarest thing i know
[Music]
i love sleep my life has the tendency to
fall apart when i'm awake you know
[Music]
write hard and clear about what hurts
[Music]
the most painful thing is losing
yourself in the process of loving
someone too much and forgetting that you
are special too
[Music]
now is no time to think of what you do
not have
think of what you can do with that there
is
there is nothing noble in being superior
to your fellow man true nobility is
being superior to your former self
[Music]
always do sober what you said you'd do
drunk that will teach you to keep your
mouth shut
[Music]
the world breaks everyone and afterward
many are strong at the broken places
i drink to make other people more
interesting
when people talk listen completely
most people never listen
every man's life ends the same way it is
only the details of how he lived and how
he died that distinguished one man from
another
but man is not made for defeat he said a
man can be destroyed but not defeated
my aim is to put down on paper what i
see and what i feel in the best and
simplest way
[Music]
i am always in love
[Music]
you can't get away from yourself by
moving from one place to another
the world breaks everyone and afterward
many are strong at the broken places
[Music]
you are so brave and quiet i forget your
suffering as a writer you should not
judge you should understand
[Music]
i'm not brave anymore darling i'm all
broken
they've broken me
[Music]
i can't stand it to think my life is
going so fast and i'm not really living
it
never to go on trips with anyone you do
not love
the best way to find out if you can
trust somebody is to trust them
you